con los hospitales al borde del colapso
eeuu registró un máximo de
hospitalizaciones el martes con 61 1964
en 24 horas las más altas cifras habían
sido registradas en abril con 59 1940 y
en julio 59 mil 718
creo que es terrible y lo que representa
es un fracaso de liderazgo
creo que está claro que la
administración de trump ha aplicado
completamente de su responsabilidad y
papel en la prevención de la propagación
de este virus y ha causado miles y miles
y miles de muertes y también miles y
miles y miles de dolor indescriptible
la noticia se conoció después de que el
lunes el país norteamericano superó los
10 millones de contagios y casi 240 mil
muertes ambas son las tasas más altas
del mundo el mismo día en el que
registró más de 130.000 nuevos casos la
segunda tasa más alta hasta el momento y
que llega tras registrar más de 800 mil
nuevos casos la semana pasada casi tres
veces más que los que registra su vecino
canadá desde que inició la pandemia
sabemos que este virus no respeta
ninguna frontera ya sea geográfica o de
ideología política y realmente nuestro
trabajo particularmente como médicos es
asegurarnos de que hacemos todo lo
posible para evitar que la gente
contraiga este horrible virus
frente a los contagios en constante
aumento varios estados están imponiendo
restricciones más importantes otros
establecen instalaciones médicas
temporales para afrontar lo que ya es la
tercera ola